specific requests from a security perspective,
because it's better equipped,
it's more intelligence to be able to handle that.
And that's what we call a proxy.
One of the ways that we can provide really good security
across a network is to use the concept
of what we call a proxy.
One of the ways that we can provide really good security
across a network is to use the concept
of what we call a proxy.
Now, if you look at that word,
if you look it up in a dictionary, for example,
it'll say acting on behalf of something else.
The idea is, as a request comes in,
we redirect it to something else
that is better equipped to make that decision.
In other words, we build something specifically
to handle specific requests from a security perspective
because it's better equipped,
it's more intelligence to be able to handle that.
And that's what we call a proxy.
A proxy typically is an application,
and because it is an application,
it's running at layer seven,
and therefore has a lot of intelligence
to be able to make decisions that we need
in order to either allow or deny certain things.
So the concept of a proxy server is exactly what you see here.
It can typically be a server that's running applications
that has intelligence to be able to make very informed
decisions about almost anything.
Perfect example of this would be
an application proxy firewall,
which is really an application that we've built
to make very informed decisions,
such as deep packet inspection, web content filtering,
or anything else that you wanna be able to do at layer seven.
And because we're doing it at layer seven,
that's where we have the most intelligence
to be able to make the best security decision.
And here is what it looks like from a diagram perspective.
You've got a client that's trying to make a connection
to a server, but that is gonna be done through something
in the middle called the proxy server,
which is really an application that's better equipped
to make that decision on behalf of all of the security rules
that we need to be able to enforce.
A different way to look at this is what you see here.
So while the perceived connection is really from client
to server, the connection is either allowed to happen
or not through the proxy.
So what we do is we redirect that decision
or that request to the proxy.
And because the proxy has been built specifically
to make that decision, it will enforce certain rules
and either allow or deny that connection to be established.
So from a user's perspective at the client,
that connection is happening from client to server,
but it's really happening through the proxy server itself,
which is again built specifically
to handle those security decisions.
And because it's an application,
it can make some really informed decisions at that level.
And so some of the things that we can do at layer seven
are things like that.
And that ends up being an application
that actually changes IP addresses to other IP addresses.
And if you think about how a company
has an internal network that you might be part of,
as you go out to the internet,
we might want to change your IP address
so that you can go out to the internet
and be routable and be able to access things.
But from a security perspective, what Nat can do
is it can change the IP address
and all of those things that look internal to the organization
so that when you go out to the internet,
anything that relates to the internal network
and its IP addressing schemes can be hidden
from anybody out there out on the internet.
So Nat can be useful in hiding our real addressing schemes
and if you remember to what all attacks require
and that is the reconnaissance phase,
you want to be able to hide a lot of what we have internally
so that they're not visible to anyone out on the internet.
So Nat can be really useful from a security perspective
because it can be used to hide your real addressing schemes
as you allow people to go out to the internet.
Now something that's part of Nat is what we call Pat.
So Nat is network address translation
which translates internal IP addresses
to routable IP addresses out on the internet
but what might be needed as part of that
is what we call Pat, port address translation
and here's how this works.
You might have a whole bunch of machines
on the internal network that are going out to the internet.
They could all use the same IP address
that they've been changed to so that they can be routable
across the outside internet.
So a whole bunch of machines can go out with the same IP address
but what would distinguish each one of them
is the port numbers that are gonna be different
for each one of those machines.
And obviously what we have to do is we have to keep track
of that so that when the request comes back
we can route it back to the machine
that originated this.
That's what Nat provides and it is part of TCP IP.
So here's a perfect example.
Let's say that you are the machine
that is making a request out to the internet.
The Nat capable device or proxy that sits at your parameters
would understand your source IP address, destination IP address,
source port and destination port and change that
to something that is routable.
But it would have to keep track of that
so that when the request comes back
we can change it back and route it back
to your specific machine.
This is what Nat and Pat can do.
And of course from a security perspective
what you need to remember is that it can be useful
in hiding our real addressing schemes
as we allow machines from the inside of the network
to actually go out to the internet and web.
Now one of the other reasons why we need Nat and Pat
is that we have what are called private address ranges
that are used by organizations internally.
And so if you're a large organization
you might be in the range of the 10 dot
that is outlined here.
As you go out to the internet
those IP addresses are not routable.
So it is Nat that needs to change it
to something that is routable.
And then when it comes back we routed back to your machine.
It's Nat and Pat that does that.
Now as far as the exam is concerned
you don't need to memorize the private IP address ranges
that are specified for example in RFC 1918
which talks about private addresses
that can be used by companies.
But these are the ones that are allocated
as being private and of course not routable
across the internet.
And that's why we need Nat and Pat
to be able to handle this nicely for us.